اقتحام الاربعاء تضمن مشهدا طرح كثيرا من
الاسئله حيث اكد شهود عيا داخل مخيم عقبه
جبر ان قوه الاحتلال اتخذت مدنيين دروعا
بشريه واظهرت صور توقيف قوات الاحتلال
لرجل يحمل طفلا الى جانب عربه عسكريه
يتجمع حولها جنود الاحتلال خلال دخولهم
الى المخيم
من جهتها قالت مقربه الامم المتحده الخاصه
بحقوق الانسان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
انها ستحقق في واقعه استخدام قوات
الاحتلال لدروع بشريه خلال اقتحامها مخيمه
عقبه جبر خلال مقابله مع الجزيره اكدت
المقرره الامميه ان استخدام الدروع
البشريه من الممارسات الشائعه لدى قوات
الاحتلال
اسرائيل بصفتها قوه احتلال لديها مسؤوليه
حمايه حياه المدنيين سنحقق في هذه القضيه
وما حدث في مخيم عقبه جبر واؤكد ان
استخدام الدروع البشريه ممارسه شائعه من
قبل اسرائيل منذ عام
1967 فنرى استخدام مدنيين فلسطينيين
للوقوف امام الجنود وكذلك ان يطلب منهم
قرع الباب قبل الاقتحام منذ عام 2000
حاولت اسرائيل اتهام الفلسطينيين بانهم هم
من يستخدمون الدروع البشريه والحقيقه ان
اسرائيل هي من تقوم بذلك وعليه يجب اثبات
وتوثيق مثل هذه الممارسات التي تقوم بها
اسرائيل
يعرف القانون الدولي الدروع البشري بانها
وضع مجموعه من الناس مدنيين او عسكريين
بشكل متعمد حول الاهداف العسكريه لردع
العدو عن مهاجمتها وقد ياخذ درع البشريه
اشكالا اخرى وضع المدنيين او الرهائن امام
قوات متقدمه لمنع العدو من التصدي لها كما
يصنف في خانه الدروع البشريه تخزين اسلحه
ومعدات وتمركز وحدات عسكريه مقاتله في
مناطق ماهوله بالمدنيين ويجرم القانون
الدولي اقدام الاطراف المتنازعه في
الصراعات والحروب على استخدام الدروع
البشريه وفق اتفاقيتي جنيف عام
1929 وعام 1949
والبروتوكول الاضافي لها عام
1977 وايضا معاهده روما عام 1998